وينضم الينا من مقر الامم المتحده في
نيويورك المتحدث باسم الامين العام للامم
المتحده
اهلا وسهلا بك نريد في البدايه ان نعرف
تقييمكم انتم في الامم المتحده لهذا الوضع
الكارثي في تركيا وسوريا بعد هذا الزلزال
هو كما قلت فعلا انه وضع كارثي وهو وهذه
الزلزال ضربه منطقه في سوريا كانت فعلا
قبل الاستنزال متاثره جدا بالنزاع وحواء
وسكان الناس في حاجه كبيره لمساعدات
الانسانيه وبالتالي اضافه ان الازمه
الانسانيه لدينا كارثه اخرى وفي تركيا
التي
ضربه قويه جدا بهذا الزلزال اذا اصيبت
الكثير محافظات
والبلدات التي كانت
كريمه جدا في اعطاء الايواء واستقبال
ملايين
اللاجئين الكثير من الاطفال والنساء
والرجال الذين تاثروا بهذه الكاسه ماساه
يحتاجون اعظم واعظم مستوى من التضامن من
المجتمع الدولي ونحن نركز جدا على ذلك طيب
على ذكر التضامن هناك تضامن من المجتمع
الدولي ولكن
هناك اشكاليه بالنسبه لدخول المساعدات الى
سوريا كيف تتعامل امم متحده مع هذه
المشكله
في سوريا احدهما تحت سيطره الحكومه
والناطق اخرى غير تابعه وغير خاضعه
للحكومه وهذا يمثل صعوباته تحديات اضافيه
لنا لكنا نوصل المساعدات للمنطقتين في
المناطق التي تحت الصدر الحكومه في الشمال
الغربي لدينا الان قافلتان في معبر باب
الهوى في حلب
ولتحمل معدات ماوى ومواد غير غذائيه
لمساعده الذين بقوا على قيد الحياه وسنرسل
المزيد في حطه نهايه هذا الاسبوع بالتركيز
على مواد محدده للنساء الحوامل او الذين
ولدوا حليد حديثا
وايضا نقدم مساعدات عن عن طريق اداء
المناطق تسيطر عليه الحكومه لدعم الجهود
تقوم بها الحكومه السوريه هناك مع منظمه
الصحه وغيرها منظمات بارسال المتعددات الى
حلب ومناطق اخرى تعرضت للكارثه واود ان
نضيف انه في كل هذه المناطق كانت هناك
مواد مساعده كانت سبقه موجوده هناك وايضا
قمنا بتوزيعها الان
قافلتان اللتان تحدثت عنهما كانت مبرمجتين
قبل الزلزال اما ان انه تمت برمجتهما بعد
حدوث الزلزال
قافلتين كانت فعلا مجدوله للدخول ولا
حقيقه وهذا كان مجدوله ام غير مجدد غير
مهم ما هو مهم هو ما يوجد على
ظهر هذه الشاحنات وما يمكن توزيعه طبعا
نحن نزيد السرعه
وكميات كلما خططنا له لايصال المزيد
مساعدات للمزيد من الناس الذين بحاجه
للمساعده بشكل كبير
فقط ست شاحنات دخلت هذه المناطق وهذا
الشيء يعني قليل جدا بالنسبه لاحتياجات
السكان هناك في هذه المناطق كيف تفسر ذلك
هذا نعم هذه حقيقه ثابته الاحتياجات كبيره
عملاقه فهنا نتحدث عن استجابه ما زالت حتى
اقل من اسبوع من الزلزال لنحاول تعبئه
اكبر الجهودي وكميات ممكنه وانا زياده
المساعدات
ولا كما قلت لك فعلا كانت مساعده موجوده
في الشمال الغربي كانت موجوده سابقا جرى
توزيعها هذه ولكن نستطيع ان نقول ان
التركيز الذي لدينا هو ان نحاول ان نوصل
اكبر كميه من المساعدات قدر الامكان لكننا
هنا نتحدث عن مناطق مدمره الطرق فيها صعبه
المرور فيها
والاتصالات صعبه جدا وبالتالي نحن نعمل
باسرع ما نستطيع
قدر ممكن في ظروف صعبه جدا
واصطاد من الخطا ان نعتقد باننا لا نركز
من المدير الامين العام الى كل المستويات
لا ننقذه على ايصال مساعداتي كل من
يحتاجها نعم ولكن سيد غوتيره العامه للامم
المتحده بالامس قال انه
هناك يعني ميه في فتح معابر اضافيه طبعا
من جهه تركيا الى اين وصلت هذه المساله
المناقشات ما زالت جاريه ما نعرفه حقا هو
انك معابر حدوديه اخرى فهمنا انها غير
المتحده تستخدمها ولكن طبعا نحن علينا ان
نتعاون ونعمل مع معايير هذه المنظمات ولكن
انا متاكد بان الاتصال مسؤولين في تركيا
وفي سوريا وما اعضاء مجلس الامن وان
الجميع يركزون على الشيء ذاته ما لا نريد
ان يحصل ونراه هو تسييس
تسييس المستندات المطلوبه النساء والاطفال
والرجال بحاجه الى مساعده كبيره ويائسه
ولابد من وضعك سياسه جانبا لايصال هذه
المساعده
الى مجلس الامن متى سيجتمع مجلس الامن
بشكل عاجل لبحث هذه المساله مساله
المساعدات مساعدات تركيا وسوريه في هذا
الازمه
عن التحدث باسم المجلس الامن لكن نعلم بان
هناك مناقشات جاريه خلال في كل بلد بين كل
دول الاعضاء لكن لتسريع عمليه المساعدات
وهذا جيش المناقشات مع سوريا وحكومه سوريا
وحكومه تركيا نعم لكن كيف تتم تنظيم عمليه
تمويل المساعدات من طرف الدول المانحه
بماذا تنصح انت سيد هناك دول تقدم لي
مناطق المعارضه مساعدات هناك دول لا تقدم
لي الحكومه السوريه من الذي يدير
المساعدات كيف تتم اداره هذه المساعدات
وبماذا تنصح هذه الدول
نصيحتنا انه بالنسبه لكل دوله عضو ان تكون
في منتهى درجات السخاء هذا يعمل لا يشمل
فقط دول الاعضاء بل ايضا قطاع الخاص
لابد ان يعطي ولان في الايام الثلاثه
ماضيه خصصنا خمسين مليون دولار من صندوق
الاستجابه الطارئه وذلك
للاطلاق الجهود مساعده من يحتاجها وايضا
نداء السريع سيعتمد على احتياجات التي
نراها ولا بد من تقييمها وما انت تعرف هذه
الارقام سنشجع الدول الاعضاء وبشكل قوي ان
يقدمه
هذا ليس بوقت الحديث عن السياسه اعتقد لو
كنتم تفكرون
بالاسر التي تحاول تعامل مع احبابها الذين
وقعوا تحت المباني لا يفكرون ولا يهتمون
بان مصدر المساعده تصلهم هذا ليس وقت
تسييس المساعدات وليس الوقت المناسب
للعقوبات هو ان الامين العام واوضح بشكل
لا لبس فيه بان العقوبات لا ينبغي اطلاقا
ان تعيق المساعدات الانسانيه لذلك دعونا
ان نركز على ما يبغي نركز عليه اوله ايصال
المساعده للملايين الذين يحتاجونها شكرا
جزيلا لك
المتحدث باسم الامين العام للامم المتحده
كنت معنا من نيويورك شكرا لك